thank you
the aforementioned Rich Eisen NFL
Network host feels like every weekend
rich is on there when I wake up and then
I go to bed I'm like I'll text Rich and
I'll be like how you how you holding up
how am I holding up how you holding up
I'm holding up yeah good to see you good
to see you how when's the first time I
met you how many years ago
um it was let me get this correct so 96
um March of 96 or February of 96 is when
I showed up and I was just observing
because there was no ESPN news yet to
throw me on yeah
um so I was observing the late Sports
Center I don't think I sat in any Big
Show meetings
um and then the story I like to tell
people is the tapes that would be used
for the late night sports center with
the same tapes that were used by you and
the highlights the highlights yeah so
they would come up in this plastic bin
that's how that's how highfalutin this
operation was a plastic bin it would
come up from the control room as soon as
they were done and I started looking at
them because I I wanted to make sure I
looked at the highlights first and I was
just locked in 26 years old felt this
presence to my left this looming Shadow
to my left and I looked up and it was
Dan Patrick looking down at me saying so
you nervous
yeah and you're all laughing because you
know exactly what I'm talking about I
know that guy he hasn't changed I know
that guy he is literally he's still
right there Frozen in time oh he's to my
left yeah as a looming presence asking
if I'm nervous I'm not nervous now but
at the time I was and so that was I
guess what uh
27 years ago is that what it was yeah 27
years my God but I was trying to break
the tension
I took it as I took it as a a sign that
you you know
just
that that you were paying attention at
all meant that you you know that I I had
caught something of your attention other
than just a I didn't see you busting
anybody else's Stones well I know I know
what the feeling was like when I went in
there and my first show was with Berman
but I got in was it yeah he stayed
it's one of the nicest gestures
anybody's ever done for me in TV I uh
Chris did the 11 o'clock Sports Center
yes and I was set to do the next Sports
Center and he said uh I'll stay and work
with the Charlotte Observer because I I
observed SportsCenter for three months
three months I just did four I just did
one month
I I can do this yeah it was three months
three and so Chris said I was going to
do my first show and he said you know
I'll do the show with you and I was
intimidated
I think it made me more nervous because
and Chris is so loud doing the
highlights like people don't realize
this you're next to him and at one point
we went to Commercial and I said God
you're loud
and he goes you could always go back to
CNN
all right oh I'm gonna shut up wow look
at you I'm going to show it at the
canyon you got the horns I did wow I did
so I I have the I would imagine the
polar opposite it was the uh the uh
anchor you refer to as Sir Lawrence of
Beale Larry Larry Beal you know who's
very understated yeah I was the
overstated one when I was doing all the
highlights I did an entire Knicks
highlight from beginning end because
this is this was my bit my Spiel my
when I was in local uh Sports in Reading
California where ESPN thank goodness
found me I don't know how they did but
they did
um at any rate and I I did an entire
Knicks highlight in Marv Albert's voice
the entire 90 seconds and Larry was on
camera next and I went Larry and he's
just like okay you know and that's that
was my first sports center uh can you
give me a little more of Albert yes I
can add it but there's different I grew
up a Marv I addict you know not not you
Marvin but the other the other Marv
um and so there's many different
marxists the excited Marv Albert last
night LeBron James yes and then there's
also the sarcastic Marv who goes low and
you know this is the tsar of the
telestrator you know so I would do all
of that stuff so you're doing 90 seconds
of that I was I was off the charts and
he was so but Berman was so nice to me
too I I don't I apologize if I'm
retelling the story on the show but uh
you recall at at the back in the day
ESPN's banners that they still have that
hang on away parties well yeah going
away parties for fans who's watching
ESPN event you could see the ESPN Banner
knowing who is broadcasting the game so
uh folks would hang them over the sides
of the prefabricated cubicles there and
ask the on-air talent to sign it for
charity yeah I'm 26 years old fresh out
of again Reading California and I'm
thinking to myself in week two
you know I don't want to be caught
signing this thing by someone like you
Dan where you'd be like how long have
you been here you know that's my name
out there you know I was afraid to sign
these things so I'm doing a 7 30 Sports
Center or seven Sports Center in 7 30
baseball tonight is next on a Sunday
Berman's in the makeup chair he's doing
the baseball tonight and I figured who
better to ask than this guy
when it's okay to sign the banners like
how long do you have to be here that's
when I asked him I'm like how many
sports centers do I have to do you
you're the guy and until I'm able to
sign these banners and he goes how many
of you done one and I'm like yeah and he
says effort sign them all and I grabbed
a Sharpie and it went down the line and
I'm like I don't care who catches me I
got Berman's check mark yeah he was so
nice about that yeah first Super Bowl
you attended first Super Bowl I attended
was as a sports center anchor uh just
off
um and hanging uh was the Ravens beating
the tar out of the Giants in Tampa
um and then the first one I covered was
Brady's second championship this is my
20th Super Bowl for NFL Network and this
was the one where he beat Jake DeLorme
who played a hell yeah moosen Muhammad
Steve Smith I mean that was a great team
that beat the Eagles by the way in the
NFC Championship Game to make the Super
Bowl and that was Brady's second and
then the next year he went back to back
so the first two years of NFL Network
were were the last back-to-back Super
Bowls I get a lot of credit for leaving
and establishing something but you were
leaving SportsCenter to go to NFL
Network and at the time we weren't quite
sure what it was right in how many
households
but you had to see something feel
something or maybe you didn't see or
feel something at ESPN and thought yeah
I can I can have this to myself I mean I
I applauded you for doing it because I
thought you can that can be your network
if you want to you were one of the few
that actually uh stuck to uh the RSVP to
my wedding after I left
there are a few empty seats at my
wedding from some people from ESPN it's
open bar rich and as a matter of fact if
I'm not Chris Fowler came on the show
the other day and I made him tell the
story that you and the uh cocktail hour
were not pleased with the I guess
alacrity of the drinks being put in your
hand and he went behind the bar himself
and started pouring for people you know
that little that little silver cone that
you you use to measure that one out the
window and just like he was like Tom
Cruise and cocktail flipping the things
around uh but we're in Central Park the
boat house that's right it's an
unbelievable Saturday it was nice and I
said the only thing missing is a good
time
no idea we come back from the pictures
like you have no idea what Dan Patrick
just did and it's true that is a fact
that is true I had people you know
backwards uh you know doing shots on the
bar with their head backed and I'm like
my mother-in-law's like what do you mean
the jagermeister's all gone
[Laughter]
but you remember you know
um back in the day uh it was kind of a
combination of a couple things just to
be really quick about it SportsCenter
went from a show of when when I first
arrived and you were making me nervous
um to the show where people tuned in to
see what happened because they either
saw it only once or hadn't seen it at
all and we were telling a story with an
on-camera lead-in and then a whole
highlight that told the story with a
score panel afterwards and then you
would toss it to the other anchor and
then back and forth a ping pong and it
was fun it was great and then uh towards
the end of the tenure Sports Center tune
turned into a show of telling you why
something happened as opposed to what
happened because it was assumed you'd
already seen it multiple times either on
the Internet or you know through this
newfangled phone thing that was in your
hand
um and so I I felt like I I had been
turned into and this was the crossfire
era uh where I'm now
um the host of a show where two analysts
come on to argue with each other this is
the beginning of a lot of these argument
shows and I'm like this is not what I
want to do only what I want to do I want
to do other things and I was told that
you can only do SportsCenter and that's
where the The Bash came in and then NFL
Network walked in the door and I can
live in Los Angeles and start something
new and Steve Bornstein was the guy who
was leading it and um he was the
president of ESPN for all those years so
I knew him and I just took the leap and
here I am 20 Super Bowls later man you
can see uh Rich Eisen NFL Network host
uh eight and a half hours started five
minutes ago and here's I'm giving you an
exclusive as soon as that eight and a
half hours is over
four days of darkness therapy I'm going
straight in yep four days of darkness
therapy after eight and a half hours of
Television I need to be alone in the
dark and uh I come through it I have no
idea what I'm gonna I'm gonna you know
what what I'm gonna do why not all that
nine hours Mike Mike I'll run that up
the flagpole yeah I'm sure I mean if I
if we're gonna round I'd round down okay
not up you know rich is also the host of
the Rich Eisen show which uh airs Monday
through Friday at noon Eastern on Roku
yeah you start to I I mean I did this
Super Bowl pregame a couple of times but
hosted in Minneapolis and it's forever
it is and you have to you have to you
know get acclimated to like it's sensory
overload the crowd and then you end the
Night by handing out the Super Bowl so
the most important thing you're going to
do is hand out the trophy at the end of
uh whatever 11 hour day or 12 hour day
and be your best don't screw up well one
time uh for a few years I did the
morning and the evening show I didn't
give up the trophy I just gave out the
highlights and then we would have guests
come by after they won the Super Bowl
Sean Payton in in Miami uh slapped me in
the uh hand when I just extended for
handstake and he just slapped it so hard
I I had that you know Brock Purdy
feeling like again word from my elbow
down to my hand I didn't feel it the
entire time because he hit it so hard uh
those were really long days you know I
remember the the Seattle Denver Super
Bowl in New York where my analysts were
asleep in the green room for the first
half of the game you know just because
you guys have been doing it but yeah
four in the morning to get to the
stadium in New Jersey at any rate it's
it's it's fun it's amazing to actually
be here I cannot believe it's 20 Super
Bowls NFL Network celebrates 20 years of
being on the air in November and it's
just a it's gonna be a great season uh
what's at stake for both of these
quarterbacks well Mahomes
um I don't think there's anything
terribly at stake to be very honest with
you for Jalen hurts other than the fact
that you never know when you're going to
get back to the game and I I don't say
that with any uh hint of uh criticism uh
I think the Eagles are set but I proper
to say if you're doing this show in Dan
Marino's first Super Bowl you would be
so we're definitely going to see him
yeah uh he never made it back so that's
potentially what's at stake that the
window of opportunity is open now irons
hot might as well strike
um and then with Mahomes this is this is
it I mean every player in the NBA is now
going to be chasing LeBron's scoring
record from here on out and then we
don't know we're assuming and he should
hit 40 000 points and Beyond by by the
time he hangs it up so now Brady's
number is fixed because he's retired for
good last I heard and so it's fixed and
if it is indeed fixed it's seven this is
now the number by which we will measure
all quarterbacks and it's not fair
because that number is absurd all those
years when Brady was winning
championships in the early part of NFL
Network were like four is the number now
it's seven so Mahomes if he does want to
get in this area code by the time he's
hung them all up he still can like if
you're looking at any quarterback who
can get in the Galaxy Brady he's the one
and winning this weekend is is the huge
First Step otherwise that's another year
off the calendar and he still sits
behind but I wonder if there's a young a
quarterback who fits in with Mahomes
being this young but this great where
you have analysts saying he might be a
top 10 quarterback of all all time so at
age 27 I think that guy is burrow if you
have to Peg one right now no but free
you know prior to this yes you know
Montana was a little bit older but you
know Elway took him time as well but can
you think of a better quarterback at a
younger age who's accomplished as much
as Muhammad I would think uh in terms of
what stats winning or something like
that winning you'd have to you you would
have to look at rust I mean Russ in the
first few years was winning two playoff
games a year not getting credit his
defense well that's that's true like
Mahomes and I think that that's where
the rust cooking thing happened you know
started to cook and now has manifested
itself into his current situation
um but Russ was really successful in the
beginning and came out of nowhere and he
had won that second one though we would
be talking about that team as being
dynastic yes and you know you could
still make the case that they were
um certainly when a handful of them will
wind up with Boston jackets at the end
of the day he uh he has a show to do
he's Rich Eisen yes and it's a Monday
through Friday noon Eastern you're here
in Scottsdale it's on Roku and also his
uh NFL game day morning I apologize you
should laugh it's an absurd it's an
absurd amount like I you know it's
amazing during the playing season how
quickly the week goes by but my entire
regular season weeks and this one is an
eternity I'm tired of reading the promo
about you doing eight and a half hours
you cramped I'm throwing that I love
football but I mean eight and a half
hour and the interesting thing is even
even with the NFL in our title and the
NFL owning our Network
um we with I think three hours to go
lose the ability to show NFL footage
because that's exclusive to who's paying
the absurd amount of money to broadcast
the Super Bowl so we have no footage so
we're just on camera a lot
talking oh yeah that's when the
celebrities like hey look who's here
with a new movie you know coming in it's
like you're doing a Telethon or
something yes we should raise money
phone calls we should raise money yeah
yes NFL Network correct yeah can I talk
to mooch please call in
stop by uh we would like that yeah
that's right hashtag Warrior Rich eyes
hey congrats thank you you're welcome
thank you pop pop the Dan Pop Pop show
yeah I got my uh yeah I got my uh cigars
somebody dropped off it's a girl my uh
my grand yeah is that right yeah okay
congratulations thanks for stopping by
anytime he's Rich Eisen of the NFL
Network Devo Samuel will join us coming
up next year Dan Patrick Show
foreign